and finally new rule white people have
to find some middle ground between
racists and people who see racism
everywhere because at this point I can't
tell who's more annoying conservatives
who don't care about anyone who isn't
white or liberals who hate themselves
because they are white there's got to be
some sweet spot between the PC police
and the Baltimore Police now I don't
know how we got to this place where
Caucasians in America are either
non-stop apologizing for the unbearable
whiteness of their being or their Trump
voters who somehow have convinced
themselves that it's white folks who
can't catch a break in America 68% of
Fox News viewers believe reverse racism
is the bigger problem racism they say
what racism look at all the black
doctors on Grey's Anatomy now these are
both stupid positions but we expect
stupid from conservatives
so let me tonight talk to the Liberals
for a minute attention whole food
shoppers
put the Cal down we need to have a talk
because this idea that being white
automatically equals lame is getting out
of hand you know who I'm talking about
the kind of person who goes away to some
exclusive vacation spot and comes back
and says it was nice but so many white
people the kind of person who watched
the Super Bowl halftime show and tweeted
some version of Coldplay just made me
sad to be white why because they're
super successful at a job you'd give
your left nut to do I know you're trying
to demonstrate to minorities that you're
a sympathetic ally by dumping on your
own whiteness but most minority folks
could give a [ __ ] they think it's
ridiculous you pretending you're making
a difference when you're just making
yourself feel better it's so white it
reminds me of how in the 90s liberals
attacked the Seinfeld joke because all
four characters were white but I don't
remember any black people caring about
it they just watch Martin instead
cut to 2016 in social justice warriors
are doing the same thing with HBO's
girls all her friends are white well I
know a lot of white people too there's
just so many in this country but hey the
person I have gotten high with the most
in my whole life and that's saying a lot
is this hard gangsta best do you mind do
I get points for that or am i furthering
the stereotype that black folks smoked
too much weed for the record they don't
I believe they smoke just the right
about
did you hear that Bernie Sanders said
the word ghetto last month and had to
spend the whole week explaining that he
didn't mean it in a good way or a bad
way or whatever way we're not allowed to
mean it
the iPhone has Suri in it they should
make one just for white people with an
app called sorry watch any sitcom
commercial movie comedy the go-to
punchline is always the tight-ass limp
dick docker wearing tiny penis bland
food eating white guy white men can't
jump they can't dance they can't [ __ ]
really even this guy he's 90 and he
still does all of them and look I'm not
saying being a white male doesn't have
its privileges of course it does I'm
just saying constantly crapping on
yourself doesn't fix anything
it's a perverse sort of narcissism the
more you hate on your own whiteness the
better person you are I hear it all the
time check your white male privilege
okay you're right I'm very privileged I
checked
now what should I tweet an apology to
Kendrick Lamar while I lap off my [ __ ]
I'm sure I'm sure that would help
because Bruce Jenner was a boob even
among Kardashians but now he has boobs
so she's Rosa Parks
I'm not saying transgender isn't an
issue either or that where people go to
the bathroom in public doesn't matter
but come on it's easily solved if you
look like a woman
use the woman's room if you look like a
man use the men's room if you're if
you're a bearded dude in a dress hold it
until you get home